foreign  [Music]  and I are absolutely delighted to be  with you today  [Music]  President John F Kennedy's moonshot  speech laid down a challenge to American  innovation and Ingenuity that inspired  me to launch the Earth shot prize  [Music]  this is a really important few days for  the Wales is to get their message over  about what the royal family has thought  [Music]  there was question after question about  no no where are you really from what  country are you from what's your  nationality where do your people come  from  [Music]  it's not helpful for the start of this  trip and I think they'll try very hard  now to move the conversation on over the  next few days